frankly that might not even be the most
embarrassing
set of clips i've seen from the media
recently the most embarrassing one might
go to the
the eulogy for the founder of hustler
larry flint i didn't actually
even realize larry larry flint had died
larry flint dies
and this guy is one of the most famous
pornographers in the country other than
hugh hefner probably the most famous one
and to show you how far
our speech regime or our understanding
of the moral order has
fallen and how much it has shifted in
recent decades
listen to the way that cbs covers the
death of this pornographer
flint fought several high-profile legal
battles and became a target for
feminists and the religious
right flint died of heart failure in los
angeles he
was 78 years old loving or hate him he
was a controversial figure
but he really did change the way people
thought about the first amendment that's
absolutely true he was also i mean it's
interesting he was he opposed the death
penalty he favored same-sex marriage
he spoke out against the u.s invasion of
iraq politically he was very progressive
he was not what you might think that
larry exactly
yeah yeah some and some reader of
hustler left a copy in a construction
site when i was 10 near my friend's
house
what'd you do with it and it changed my
life forever
and here you are on pbs how about that
this is very embarrassing for these
people on on many levels it's funny line
you know
i found this this porn mag and it
changed my life forever when i was 10
years old
i think that's true you know i think
that actually is true
part of the reason right now that on the
right this porn debate has come up this
question should we regulate porn or ban
porn
you'll notice it's come up not from gen
x or the boomers or even millennials
it's really come up from gen z
why because gen z is the first
generation that grew up
with the internet all the time basically
in a world saturated by not just a
little nudie magazine but by
high-speed internet porn from the age of
10 or whenever i think on average it's
people are about 11 years old when they
first discover porn
in these younger generations and it can
really ruin your life
you know it can really make your life a
lot harder i think
people make fun of these zoomers when
they say we need to regulate porn
they say oh yeah you probably look at
porn yeah they probably do
because something like what is it 92 or
something of men
look at certainly have looked at porn i
think in terms of have seen
naked ladies on the internet it's like
92 percent of men have done it and eight
percent of men are lying is what what
people say about the
the statistics yes they realize it's a
real problem and larry flint
is in no small part responsible for that
i
couldn't get over it when that reporter
said you know though believe it or not
larry flint was politically very
progressive
gee you don't say oh i thought he was a
conservative republican i thought he was
like edmund burke but oh he's
progressive the pornographer wow
shocking
yeah larry flint when republican
politicians would oppose
the ubiquity of porn he would go in and
try to gin up sex scandals for them
in the 1990s he endorsed mark sanford in
2013
for south carolina's first congressional
district because he said quote his open
embrace of his mistress in the name of
love
breaking his sacred marriage vows was an
act of bravery that has drawn my support
that guy should be canceled that kind of
that sort of culture
should be canceled that view of the
first amendment which is completely at
odds with the
with the understanding of our founding
fathers and the history most of the
history of our country
that should be cancelled it has to be
you can't have both views
you can't have the view of the founding
fathers of the first amendment and the
modern view
at the same time one view says we need
to prioritize liberty not licentiousness
licentiousness will destroy liberty that
modern view says licentiousness is
liberty
can't have them both you've got to pick
one we should pick the founding fathers
we can all pray for larry flint's soul
but when we think about his legacy we
should not
celebrate it in the way that that cbs is
doing if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
you